well welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies to your house well
I kind of made me think I mean this is
sort of a perfect opportunity
ladies and gentlemen Tom Segura Master
Alexis
now dodo it's too close to where the car
come from that's really good I know what
region is this London this yeah just
keep listening but it's an idea I have
never been in a car like this
this car will leave anything for us well
anything I'll dust it come move a
commode he saw a free BMW it's a i3 BMW
that's really good yeah and I can move
it sounds retarded
I've got eats against them that's why I
can do our drive to BC be targeted I'm
gonna put it in my flats not my mum's no
never mind less I'm a pair my block not
my mum's but don't they have dash cams
in Europe everywhere in the car's not my
mom pretty common now that they do this
in Europe like how the fuck do you not
know that every car has a dash cam on it
is every car well in Russia I know they
do it yeah it's pretty prevalent because
car thievery is prevalent but this bait
AB W can move that and people getting
hit and stuff accidents so they a lot of
them have - the way you're saying yeah
is Europeans are not just naked all the
time but have to actually recording it
all yeah yeah yeah this car can't wear
wear bulb that similar yeah I'm yeah I
keep you know way a new middle spillways
what a fucking race on No Middlesex
Hospital no holidays outfit oh he looks
like he sounds like he's mocking
somebody's right British right holy shit
really bad what is this accent called
what is this master of accents this is
God I'm fucking you no way
Middlesboro is no man I hope that boss
better Middlesex Hospital Mittal say oh
I'll spit okay hi this is bad
yeah it's really terrible it talks like
uh you know with no misse-x
o sweet o is total brick calm I said
I've got the curve telly
I've got bass boxes in my eyes my eyes
he's crazy my proper study all that both
my Mac is this guy's this is like a Guy
Ritchie movie character Roebuck yes Baba
yeah you're right it is like that like
the they talk to gypsies and you can
understand this has gotta be love that's
how London yeah but this guy's like oh
yeah whatever they call lower-class
speaking of master of actions you know
I'm not the only one and they exist in a
bunch of different places
okay we have found the Japanese master
of accents okay doing our accent I love
when foreigners do America it's the
nominal I would like a cheeseburger come
to Yan Jean King double ceramic knives
manufacturer Company Limited which is a
specialist to manufacturer and exporter
of ceramic knives we have a domestic
production equipments and a superior
technical personnel who has more than
ten years a ceramic knife making
experience at small 81st and a
continuous innovation is our persistent
aim
yeah my favorite part of these cut
tenderest is that you know on the food
chain of this company they don't know
that what he sounds like to native it
yes somebody's like have you heard
shogen speak English
yeah it's fucking amazing yeah yeah and
he'll do he'll do a perfect kind tenon
already he's like I don't know that's
not what he's having our knives
what cuts were editing that we focus our
attention on manufacturing matters
various kinds of knowledge a vote and a
fly ecology ceramic knife wine quality
so a taster cuz it's a quality quality
another component
the problem woke well hadn't a survivor
ceramic knives his over ninety degree
that's a gray the problem is is that he
learned British English first
uh-huh so he's doing it with a British
accent and then trying to do American on
top of it yeah cuz he's not only going
British right he should have just done
like but he learned to speak at British
nose
oh very strong sounds like a retarded
Asian that's why I can do it stung know
that good no hey you haven't really done
the retarded comedian idea babe you're
missing out on a huge market do this
accent go I have to hear it it can stand
up to meters drop test do to use ma can
stand up to meters drop tests dropped a
throaty intensity and a tough case I
love our ceramic products and exported
to Europe which have been winning
customers appreciation you know what he
sounds like he is palsy like it's their
rhenium polity why does this company you
think not just hire an English speaker
there's gotta be some right in Asia of
course and then they go but show Jen is
he's here Oh Jack just use him that's
not even a name is it this is show - Joe
chin pushing that's all I can you make
that second read English crown patreon
put that down
Oh along currently we can make to carry
falling pieces of ceramic knives
annually PC terrible 245 PC is my as a
pauper
Oh baby I'm table yeah Pacey's ah this
is Bert oh yeah you there's someone that
speaks English better than that guy